So you have stretch marks and you want
to get rid of it? Well join the club
because there's actually a lot more guys
out there with stretch marks than you
think. Even in teens, it's estimated that
40% of guys have stretch marks. So can
you get rid of it and if you can how do
you do it? Well I'm gonna tell you so
let's start the video:
Just very quick: If you're new here on my channel, welcome!
I'm Daniel and I've been a male model for
over 13 years and on this channel I give
you tips that's got to do with
grooming, style, fitness and any men's
issues. So consider subscribing and also
clicking that notification bell so you
won't miss any of the next videos. Now is
it possible to get rid of stretch marks?
Well, to be honest, it's one of the most
difficult skincare concerns out there to
deal with. Because there are no products on the market that can get rid of stretch
marks completely. But there is a few
things that can really help you out and
that's what I'm gonna talk about. So
let's start with the first one
The first one is you can use a good quality
cream that contains retinol. It's one of
the only ingredients that's shown to
improve the appearance of stretch marks
Good options are dr. Dennis gross
anti-aging moisturizer and Paula's
Choice resist. I'll add it for you in the video description like always so you can go
and do your own research.
Now retinol is also found in good
quality anti-aging products because it
helps those fine lines and wrinkles.
The way retinol works is that it builds
collagen making collagen bundles thicker
and healthier. You can also get
prescription retinoids which are stronger
than the products of retinoids that you
get over the counter
Laser therapy. Laser therapy is one of
the best options out there. I think it is
the best actually, because it is backed
up by studies and it shows that people
who went for laser therapy saw an
improvement in the appearance of their
scars between 50 and 75 percent which is
a lot. Now if you do want to take this
route you can go and see your
dermatologist because they'll be able to
help you out. If you don't have the money or you feel uncomfortable with doing laser
therapy you can try chemical peels. To be
specific TCA peels. Why TCA appeals?
Well, because TCA peels penetrate further than AHA or BHA peels. So they are better at
stimulating collagen and elastin for the
depth of damage in the stretch marks
Just some last advice: It's important to
keep your expectations realistic because
you won't be able to get rid of stretch
marks completely and remember those
stretch marks they're carrying your
story. What you went through so for
example guys who were heavily
overweight and you lost that weight
Then you have those stretch marks and you earned those stripes.
if you liked the video give it a thumbs up subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video
Cheers!